[Musique]
dis moi comment reconnaît-on l'intérieur
d'une personne
[Musique]
bonjour votre majesté ou résident
l'amour la vérité
la mecque
[Applaudissements]
nos pensées ou la folie
[Musique]
comme souvenir
de grâce souvenez vous
[Musique]
et m'a volé notre vous oubliez la
manière dont on salue un roi
javaux gens c'est à moi ophélie il se
passe des choses étranges ce château il
te faut craindre la seule sauvegarde
c'est la crainte
nous pouvons prendre la fuite venez tu à
monter mon fils contre moi je pense qu
ophélie est très dangereuse il valait me
marier à un autre
ça commence maintenant
emmenez là
[Applaudissements]
la vengeance la folie la perte d'un
royaume
rien n'est comme il y paraît